the Golden Globe announced their
nominations today controversial already
there are zero women nominated in the
best director category yeah a lot of
people a lot of people feel that's a
huge oversight in a year with so many
incredible movies and TV shows directed
by women we wanted to give the Hollywood
Foreign Press a chance to explain
themselves so please welcome via
satellite their spokesperson Luke do
Boucher hello Luke Boucher Konan hello
there the Hollywood Foreign Press deeply
apologizes for this oversight and this
will not happen again thank you okay no
no no get back here get back here do not
walk away we have to address this now
sir you're not concerned that women
aren't being recognized for their
contributions to film of course not
we anticipate Christian Bale will thank
his wife in his acceptance speech and I
think it would be a major
acknowledgement for women everywhere no
no no they yes people are booing it's
clearly not the same thing well come on
why is this one category getting all the
attention time how come no one is
talking about the great man who were
snubbed in the Best Actress category
what are you talking about men aren't
allowed in that category well obviously
we still have a long way to go no you
don't now come on how are you gonna make
this right this is terrible okay well
this year every woman who attends the
ceremony will receive an official Golden
Globes apron now okay why aren't the men
getting aprons why would they need them
Springer crowd tonight hey you're lucky
you're on satellite sir this mob would
kill you
now come on this is clearly gender bias
can you even name a woman in Hollywood
that's assert there are so many okay
fine then name one uh uh I got one not
Oprah Oh done Cary Grant no wait a
minute that was a man really Carrie you
gotten down that's the country me no no
you're a man
this those are your keys really then why
am i aroused
Oh for god sake
[Applause]